what is time in all this we kind of
mentioned it a bunch
um is it not important at all in terms
of uh is it just a word should we be
talking about causality mostly like sir
what do you think
is
uh we've talked about like memories is
that the fundamental thing that we
should be thinking about and and time is
just a useful measurement device or
something like that well there's
different concepts of time right so i
think in assembly theory when we're
talking about time we're talking about
the ordering of things so that's the
causal graph part and so then the
fundamental structure of the universe is
that there is a certain ordering
and certain things can't happen until
other things happen but usually when we
colloquially attack colloquially talk
about time we're talking about the flow
of time um
and i guess lee and i were actually
debating about this this morning so and
talking on it walking on the river here
which is a very lovely spot for talking
about time um but that the you know that
when the universe is updating it's
transitioning between
things that exist now and things that
exist now um
uh that's really the flow of time
so there's there's
you have to separate out those concepts
at bare minimum and then there's also an
arrow of time that people talk about in
physics which is that time doesn't
appear to have a directionality in
fundamental physics but it does um
to us right like we can't go backwards
in time and usually we you know that
would be explained in physics in terms
of um well there's a cosmological arrow
of time but there's also the
thermodynamic arrow of time of
increasing entropy
um but what we would say in assembly
theory is that there is a clear
directionality the universe only runs in
one direction which is why some things
it's easy to make if the universe ones
and runs in one direction it's easy to
make processes look reversible for
example if they have no memory they're
easy to run forward and backwards which
is why the laws of physics that we have
now look the way they do because they
involve objects that have no memory but
when you get to things like us it
becomes very clear that the universe has
a directionality associated to it so
it's not reversible at all it's the um
no man ever steps in the same river i
just have to bring that out because you
will yeah on the river no man has ever
steps in the same river twice for it's
not the same river and he's not the same
man uh so that it's not reversible any
of this no no but reversibility is an
emergent property right so we think of
the reversibility of laws as being
fundamental and the irreversibility is
being emergent but i think what we would
say
from how we think about it and certainly
sees the case for our perception of time
but also you know what's happening in
biological evolution
you can make things reversible but it
requires work to do it and it requires
certain machines to run it forward and
backward and akira marletta was working
some interesting ideas and constructor
theory related to that which is totally
different set of ideas so you can travel
back in time
sometimes yes
you can
not you can't travel actually back in
time but you could reconstruct yeah you
tried things that have existed in the
past you're always moving forward in
time but you can cycle through like i i
mean can i clarify yeah yeah go for it
quickly you travel forward in time to
travel back yes
that thank you that really clearly
what what's sarah saying you don't go
back in time you recreate what happened
in the past in the future and inspect it
again so in that local pocket of time
it's as if you travel back in time so i
don't
how's that not traveling back in time
because you're not going back to your
same self back in time you are you're
creating that in the future what else is
the same as it was in the past no
no no no it's not in registry i mean it
goes back to the big question i'm saying
i mean this is something
i i was trying to look up today when i
first we first had this discussion and i
was talking to sarah on skype and i said
by the way
time because time is the fundamental
thing in the universe she almost hung up
on me right but but you can even i mean
if you want to make an analogy to
computation and i think charles bennett
actually has a paper on this like about
reversible computation and reversible
turing machines in order to make it
reversible you have to store memory to
run the process backwards
so
time is always running forward in that
because you have to write the memory
erase the memory
you can erase the memory but the point
it
when you go back to zero right but the
whole point is that in order to have a
process that even runs in both
directions you have to start talking
about memory to store the information to
run it backwards i got it so you can't
really then
you can't have it exactly how it was in
the past yeah you exactly so you either
have extra stuff extra baggage always
okay a really important thing i want to
say on this i think if i try and get it
right to say that if you can think that
the universe is expanding in terms of
the number of
boxes that it has to store states
right
and this is where the directionality of
the universe comes from everything comes
from you could erase what's in those
boxes but the fact you've now got so
many boxes at time now in the in this
present there's more of those boxes than
there were in the past see but the boxes
aren't physical boxes
they
why is the number of boxes always
expanding it's very hard to imagine this
because we live in space
so what i'm saying which is i think
probably correct
is that we just let's just imagine for a
second
there is a non-local situation but there
are these things called states
and the universe
um irrespective of whether you measure
anything
there is a universal let's call it a
clock or a state creator
maybe we can call it this way maybe you
can call it god but let's call it a
state creator where the universe is
expanding in the number of states it has
why are you saying it's expanding though
is that obvious that it's expanding it's
obvious because that's where the because
um we
we
that's a source of novelty it's a source
of novelty and it also explains why the
universe is not predictable um and you
know it's not predictable well i just
like interrupting you i'm sorry it's fun
as you're struggling i'm struggling
because it's but i'm trying to be as
concrete as possible and not sound like
i'm insane yeah um and i'm not insane
it's it's obvious because you
did um
i'm a chemist so as a chemist i grew
into the world understanding
irreversibility all irreversibility is
all i knew
and when people start
telling me the universe is actually
reversible it's a magic trick we can use
time to do it so what i mean is the the
the second law
is um
really the
magical
but why does it need to be magical the
universe is just asymmetric all i'm
saying is the universe is asymmetric in
the state production
and we can erase those states but we
just have more computational power so
what i'm saying is that the universe's
deterministic horizon this is one of the
reasons we can't live in a simulation by
the way
the ur we can't live in a simulation the
irreversibility yeah so basically every
time you try and simulate the universe
in this you know live in a simulation
the universe has expanded in states
you're like oh damn it i need to make my
computer bigger again and every time you
try and contain the universe in the
computation because it's got bigger a
number of states and so i'm saying
the fact that universe has novelty in it
is going to turn out experimentally to
be proof
that time
as i've labeled it is fundamental
and exists as a physical thing that
creates space
okay so if you can prove
that novelty is always being created
you're saying that it's possible to also
then prove that it's always expanding in
the state space
those are things that to be
have to be proven that's what working
experiments for yeah and you're trying
to like by looking at the sliver of
reality
show that there's always novelty being
generated yeah
because if we go and live in a universe
that the conventional physicists would
live in it's a big lookup table of stuff
and everything exists
i want to prove
that that book is
that book doesn't exist it's
continuously being added pages on so all
i'm saying is the universe is a book we
started the universe at the beginning
only had no pages and they have or had
one page another page another page
whereas a physicist would now say all
the pages exist and we could in
principle access them i'm saying that is
fundamentally incorrect
you